remember if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
it was very difficult for me to figure
out where my boundaries were because I'd
grown up poor and didn't have anything
impossible is not a fact it's an opinion
what's up belief nation it seven I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the eight
things that you must do if you want to
have success also if you want to know at
Elon Musk Oprah Will Smith and others
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below there are times
when something is important enough you
believe it enough that you do it in
spite of the fear key to success is what
you believe is true for yourself I was
excited about taking a shot the fact
that it was so strange
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one acted despite fear with Elon Musk or
unusually fearless and willing to go in
the face of other people telling you
something that's crazy and I know a lot
of pretty crazy people you still stand
out where does that come from or how do
you think about making a decision when
everyone tells you this is a crazy idea
where do you get the internal strength
to do that well first of all I'd say I
actually think I feel feel fear quite
strongly so it's not as though I just
have the absence of fear I've I feel it
quite strongly but there are times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that you do it in
spite of fear so speaking of important
things like people shouldn't think III I
should if you should think well I feel
fear about this and therefore I
shouldn't do it it's normal to be to
feel fear like you'd have to do
something mentally wrong you shouldn't
feel fear so you just feel it and let
the importance of it drive you to do it
anyway yeah you know actually we're
something that can be helpful as
fatalism some degree if you just think
it's just accept the probabilities then
that diminishes fear so I'm starting
SpaceX I thought the odds of success
were less than 10% and I just accepted
that actually probably I would just lose
lose everything but that maybe would
make some progress if we could just move
the ball forward even if we died maybe
some other company could pick up the
baton and move and keep moving it
forward so that were still do some good
yeah same with Tesla I thought your odds
of a car company succeeding were
extremely low rule number two learn from
the mistakes of others with Jack Ma my
thinking is that you guys remember if
you want to be successful learn from the
other people's mistakes don't learn from
the successful stories successful
stories they may don't listen to that
there are a lot of reasons behind it
just like God
I remember the first time Harvard
Business School came to us say J we want
to write a case study for you
yes years 2001 a 2000 became the spend
one week and they write a report and I
read now I said this is not me and this
is this is you as a no this is not us is
that this is you so they make a be sign
and the case study go up and they start
to teach in love universities the next
of five years they invite to need to go
to the case study and they always find a
competitor of my company and F after
every case that case study Ali Papa
would die that company will succeed all
the students are green and actually
every five years all the competitive
dive is justified so how can you study
this kind of a success of a start learn
from the mistakes the other people no
matter how smart you are you will
encounter these mistakes you learn from
mistakes not because you will be able to
avoid mistakes you were able to when
these mistakes come they suffer comes
you know how to deal with it how to face
it
I write the book I want to write if I if
I want if I can
it's a re Bubber 1001 mistake this is
the most rational things that in my life
in my life is not how much we achieved
it is how much we go through the tough
days and mistakes and this is what you
see if you step to think now would be
good rule number three set boundaries
with Oprah Winfrey I first started
making money and it was you know my
salary or my earnings were published all
over the place I mean the first year I
was like really did I make that much
money oh my god it was very difficult
for me to figure out where my boundaries
were because I'd grown up poor and
didn't have anything so it's easy when
you don't have anything then people ask
you for money they say I need 500
I don't have it because I'm just trying
to get my rent paid it's harder when
you're multi billion dollar salary is
now into paper and you get a lot of
friends and cousins you didn't have
before so how do you set boundaries for
yourself I was having trouble setting
boundaries myself for myself for even
strangers people would just show up at
my door in Chicago and say Oprah I left
my husband please help me and I would
because she knows I have it so don't try
that now though okay don't try that now
I figured it out so what I learned was
is that oh the reason why people keep
showing up is because my intention is to
make them think that I'm such a nice
person that you can ask me for anything
you can get me to do anything I'm gonna
say yes I'm gonna say yes so when Stevie
called me this time I thought I'd try
out my first no on Stevie let's start
big he wanted me to donate some money to
a charity and I didn't want to donate to
the charity because I have my own
charities and I care about a lot of
people but the problem is when you you
have money everybody thinks you just
want to give to everything so every
letter I ever get starts with we know
you love the children
yes I do love the children but somebody
else is gonna have to help the children
so I said to Stevie I said to Stevie no
and as a person who has that disease to
please I was waiting for him then just
to say I will never speak to you again I
will never call you I will never sing a
song for you and he didn't he just said
okay okay okay it's okay he said okay
check you later and what I learned from
that is many times you will have angst
and worry about things and put yourself
in a state like someone said this
morning because her phone went off they
were mortified over a phone I said
really you will put yourself in a state
when the other person really isn't even
thinking about you so learning that I
could specifically determine for myself
what the boundaries were for me what I
wanted to do give my money give my time
give of my service to who I wanted to
give it to when I did that I get to make
that decision and just because you get a
hundred requests a week doesn't mean you
have to try to fulfill all of that just
because you have all of these demands on
your time and on you doesn't mean that
you have to say yes you get to decide
because you're the master of your fate
the captain of your soul is William
Ernest Henley said in Invictus and
understanding that really change the
meaning of my life and that I was not no
longer driven by what other people
wanted me to do but took charge of my
own destiny making choices based upon
what do I feel is the next right move
for me rule number four choose a life of
adventure with Jeff Bezos you can choose
we all get to choose our life stories
and it's the choices that define
it's not our gifts everybody in this
room has many gifts I have many gifts
you can never be proud of your gifts
because their gifts they were given to
you you might be you know tall or you
might be really good at math or you
might be extremely beautiful or handsome
or you know there are there many gifts
and you can only be proud really of your
choices because those are the things
that you are that you're that you are
acting on and one of the most important
choices that each of us has and you know
this just as well as I do is you can
choose a life of ease and comfort or you
can choose a life of service and
adventure and when you're 80 which one
of those things you think you're going
to be more proud of you're gonna be more
proud of having chosen a life of service
or adventure rule number five break the
rules with simon Sinek let me tell you a
story so a friend of mine and I we went
for a run in Central Park the
Roadrunners organization on the weekends
they host races and it's very common at
the end of the race they'll have a
sponsor who will give away something
apples or bagels or something and on
this particular day when we got to the
end of the run there were some free
bagels and they had picnic tables set up
and on one side was a group of
volunteers on the table were boxes of
bagels and on the other side was a long
line of runners waiting to get their
free bagel so I said to my friend let's
let's get a bagel and he looked at me
and said that lines too long and I said
free bagel and he said I don't want to
wait in line and I was like free bagel
and he says not that's it's too long and
that's when I realized that there's two
ways to see the world some people see
the thing that they want and some people
see the thing that prevents them from
getting the thing that they want I could
only see the bagels he could only see
the line
and so I walked up to the line I leaned
in between two people put my hand in the
box
and pulled out two bagels and no one get
mad at me because the rule is you can go
after whatever you want
you just cannot deny anyone else to go
after whatever they want
now I had to sacrifice choice I didn't
get to choose which bagel I got I got
whatever I pulled out but I didn't have
to wait in line so the point is is you
don't have to wait in line you don't
have to do it the way everybody else has
done it you can do it your way you can
break the rules you just can't get in
the way of somebody else getting what
they want that's rule number one
rule number six be obsessed with Will
Smith he told the famous story behind
you kind of backed into acting Fresh
Prince of bel-air yeah and the next
thing you know you start making these
movies and I forget that bad boys
actually came before Independence Day
right yeah tennis day just was like one
of the biggest of all time like what was
that transition like for you yeah you
know actor and like the biggest actor in
the game no it was um that was like the
first real goal like that in terms of
setting goals I was like I want to be
the biggest movie star in the world
right and every up until that point
everything was like it was fun and it
was happening and we were creating in
Jeff's mom's basement and it was
successful but that was like when I
moved into acting that was the first
time I started applying skill to my my
talents right and you know I always look
I look at skill and talent separately
like Pete you're born with talent you
know it's like there's certain things
that you just do naturally you were
gifted with a talent and you have it but
skill is acquired through discipline and
you know I've never seen myself as
particularly talented where I excel is
I'm willing to die in the process of
acquiring skill like is you know when I
put my obsessive mind on a sign the trap
I'm just
exactly yes not working yes is a
ridiculous and sickening working
sickening work ethic exactly it's like
you know so for me to be a movie star
was the first thing that I ever really
wanted like that and set my he was like
I was like you know because I went out
when I looked I always felt like there
weren't a lot of people I saw do things
that I felt like I couldn't do right
when I when I look at people and I see
things I don't I don't feel like I can't
whether or not I will is something
different but I don't ever feel like I
can rule number seven change your story
with Tony Robbins when something is
considered quote/unquote impossible how
do you reframe it so it becomes possible
in your mind and how much of that is
mindset I think impossible is not a fact
it's an opinion when someone tells me
it's impossible
I always just look at anybody around me
knows that they can do this that's part
of it but if they didn't know me it's
your opinion then I'll say no science
shows and I say yeah I know how many
times the science shows something's
impossible now science shows it's
possible things are impossible till
somebody does it and so I find that you
know most of your business people you
look at businesses and what does it take
to make a business grow it's not
impossible like a business grow this has
been shrinking for a long time or it's
been stuck
the real problem is always the chokehold
as always the psychology and the skills
of the leader always an 80% of that as
psychology and 20% as the mechanics like
if you don't know how to read your
financials and you're trying to fly the
plane of your your company I mean come
on you know if all you do is go down you
look at profit loss and you see what it
is and you have a beer either way you
either celebrated at the brass you know
something you know you're gonna be in
trouble right but if you have the
skillsets that's one thing but you can
get any skill set at the other
psychology and anytime a business is not
growing it is not because it's
impossible it's because they are
innovating and they're not innovating
because they're believing it's
impossible I mean if we all know what
does it take to transform now obviously
oh people it takes three things to
create a breakthrough and anything and
your personal life and your
business anywhere you need a strategy
but that's not the first place she's
looking at the first place all of us
look me too
it's our inherent thing you want to lose
weight well how do I do it I want to
grow my business how do I do it it's
it's instinctively been trained to think
that way but the problem is the how-to
is usually not that complex Anna come on
70% of America is what 75% of America
now is overweight is that because it's
so complex that have you fit and strong
right you know only the 1% no the answer
is they hide it from you you have to
work your ass off to not hear what it
takes right and so so you know I
remember I went to this I went to a TED
med Center and I watched about 12
doctors what I have to know to get up
and do these stories about how we could
just get patients to take their
medications and try to figure out the
whole thing and I was just looking and
going you're all talking about strategy
you've forgotten psychology because
strategy's wonderful I'm a strategist
I'm my whole life figure out strategies
we both know a strategy could save you a
decade right and business strategy could
save you you know it could make the
difference T in success and failure but
most people have strategies available or
they could get them or you could create
them but the problem is you got a story
and your story is why it isn't working
and the story is I've tried what but
everything if you tried everything you'd
be fit you tried everything you'd be
profitable if you tried everything you'd
be there but people said you know I'm
big-boned that's what I used to say I'm
still big-boned but I'm 38 pounds
lighter than I was 25 years ago and I've
never gained it back right a borrow his
big bone that was my story all the good
ones are gone that's why I'm not in a
relationship or the Gann I'm not or
in-game they are whatever the story is
there's always a story and what I tell
people's you know if you can just
divorce the story of your limitation and
marry the truth of your unlimited
capacity then the whole game changes and
rule number eight the last one before a
very special bonus clip is read with
Warren Buffett I should mention one
thing about reading it was at the
library here at Columbia I wish I spent
probably more time than any other
I live there practically but and I
pulled the book out there happen to be
who's in America and it told me
something about my professor Benjamin
where I am and then I looked up and I
went to the library and I said I want to
learn more about this because I learned
this over here that changed my whole
life
you know we owned I go now because of
that library and directing me to some
other book and then following through on
that night it's the chance I I really
did my 1/5 the pace the bill does but I
still spend five or six hours of
everything I mean it just you can learn
so much I particularly love biography
just you know to be able to live the
lives of these people have been extorted
see them so extraordinary the lessons
and the you know the discouragements
they face just everything about it so I
did you can't get enough of reading
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Robert Kiyosaki on how to learn how
to sell that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
in your business and if you're feeling
bold leave your answers in the comments
below here we go
question number one what are you afraid
of and how will you step into that fear
today number two what new boundary do
you need to set for yourself and number
three what new book will you commit to
reading this week
I am very shy very very shy and I came
back from Vietnam and I could kill
people but I couldn't talk to people and
one day I said to my my I decided to
follow my rich dad's footsteps I just
said to him I want to be an entrepreneur
he says you got one problem I said
what's that so if you're shy I said
what's wrong with being shy says you
gotta sell you got to handle rejection
number-one skill
can you handle rejection answers no I
couldn't handle it so I stole the wallet
I would sell so without this is the 1973
I was 25 years old and my Rich Dad said
how's your love life so it sucks so
getting laid they said no so it's cuz
you can't sell guys got it so when I
talk about what skill do you need when
the [ __ ] hits the fan
you better start selling so I went to
work for Xerox in 1974 so I gotta learn
how to sell it took me four years then I
was number one okay and today I'm a
best-selling author
you know most PhD is telling me I can't
write yes I said I can't write but I
can't sell if you can't sell you don't
make money period and the statement you
know just because you have a product
doesn't mean jack
but the important thing is you start you
know I don't care what product you start
with but you start and I started off
with dylon wallets success wiped me out
you know we couldn't sell could itself
also they took off then I couldn't
finance I couldn't finance to put in
finance but the sales kept going through
the roof now trouble is I can't
borrowing and they couldn't sustain the
sales next lesson but that's how we
learn okay raise your standard Apple at
the core its core value is that that
people need passion and now one drop of
most self-worth depends on your it's
supposed to mean
if you like this video check out the one
we did on the 20 best pieces of advice
every aspiring entrepreneur needs to
hear the link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
your real work is to figure out